[Music]
my name is Tamar Gendler I'm professor
of philosophy and cognitive science and
chair of the philosophy department at
Yale University
so philosophy comes from the Greek term
meaning love of wisdom Philo love Sophia
wisdom and every culture from time
immemorial has had a philosophical
tradition there are philosophical
traditions in Western culture that have
their roots in ancient Greece there are
philosophical traditions in Eastern
culture great Chinese and Indian
philosophical traditions there are
philosophical traditions in Africa there
are philosophical traditions in native
cultures throughout the world what
philosophy does in every Society of
which it's a part is asks the question
why why are things the way they are and
should they be that way the Western
philosophical tradition to which my
comments today will be restricted can be
divided into two main segments on the
one hand it has a descriptive component
which asks about how things are and how
we know that and on the other hand it
has a normative component a component
which asks about how things ought to be
so into the first category fall
questions like what's the fundamental
nature of reality does God exist do we
have free will and likewise questions
about how we know about the fundamental
nature of reality those branches of
philosophy are known as metaphysics
fundamental questions about what there
is and epistemology fundamental
questions about how we know things on
the other side of the divide are the
questions that I've called normative
questions
questions about values and that segment
of philosophy has three main parts one
of them aesthetics is concerned with the
question what's beautiful and what makes
it so the second part of that division
of philosophy moral philosophy asks the
question what is morally right or good
and the third part of that division of
philosophy political philosophy asks the
question how should societies be
structured in order to allow human
flourishing and what makes societal
structures legitimate perhaps the most
accessible and exciting part of
philosophy for people who have never
encountered the discipline before he is
political philosophy which asks
questions that we as citizens of a
democracy need to ask ourselves in order
to be responsible participants in our
joint governance questions like what's
the best way for society to be
structured in order to allow people to
flourish what's the appropriate division
of rights and responsibilities in a
society how should the legitimate
concerns of liberty and equality be
balanced and for those of you who are
interested in studying a subject that
has practical import it may be worth
realizing that political philosophy
brought you the world as you know it
today
political philosophy brought the world
Greek democracy it brought us the Magna
Carta it brought us the French
Revolution and the American Revolution
it brought us communism it brought us
the civil rights movement it brought us
feminism and libertarianism it even
brought us the Tea Party It was as a
result of thinking about these sorts of
questions that these movements came into
being so I want you to start by asking
yourself
how you would answer these questions
should the state guarantee universal
health care should there be an
inheritance tax should there be a draft
army and should you be allowed to sell
your vote the three people we'll meet in
the lecture are Thomas Hobbes who wrote
a great book called Leviathan in 1651
John Rawls who wrote a book called
theory of justice in 1971 and Robert
Nozick who wrote a book called Anarchy
state and utopia in 1974 it's been said
of political philosophy that political
philosophy asks two questions who should
get what and who says so and you might
think of the three authors that we're
going to discuss as answering those
questions in different ways Thomas
Hobbes is primarily concerned with the
second question who says so what makes
the state legitimate and John Rawls and
Robert Nozick are in a conversation
directly with one another about the
question who gets what
[Music]
so Thomas Hobbs lived at the end of the
1500s and beginning of the 1600s roughly
at the time of Shakespeare but the
questions with which he's concerned in
his great book Leviathan aren't
questions that just apply to his time
they're questions that concern us today
as well he asks the question what would
the world be like if there wasn't a
state and would that situation be better
or worse than the situation where there
is some form of governance in particular
Hobbes famously asks people to imagine
what life would be like in what he calls
the state of nature a situation in which
there's no external governing body and
Hobbes points out that in the state of
nature people are all roughly equal in
the following relevant way all of us no
matter how physically strong or
intellectually clever are at risk of
having the work that we do disrupted by
others at risk of having the property
that we've acquired taken by others at
risk of having the things that we see as
important to our lives destroyed by
others because all of us sleep and all
of us go away from things that are
important to us as a result says Hobbes
in the state of nature people need to
expand a tremendous amount of energy
protecting their goods there's no
opportunity in the state of nature to do
the sorts of things which human beings
think makes life valuable all of those
things Hobbes points out are passable
only because you have a kind of security
and safety
by contrast life in the state of nature
says Hobbes is solitary poor nasty
brutish and
short the question is how can we get out
of the state of nature how can we get
out of this situation of perpetual fear
soraa's Hobbes points out active war
isn't what disrupts human activity the
fear of war is sufficient to disrupt
human activity think of the ways in
which after 9/11 your anxiety about your
security was raised so that at every
moment you were attentive to things
around you hyper-vigilant - what risks
you might face so Hobbes idea in arguing
for the legitimacy of government is to
begin by asking what would it be like if
there were no government and to point
out that that's a state which all of us
find undesirable in subsequent years
game theorists who work at the
intersection of what you might think of
as philosophy and economics have
developed a way of representing the
problem which Hobbes thinks we face in
the state of nature life in the state of
nature according to Hobbes embodies what
sometimes called a prisoner's dilemma
the prisoner's dilemma gets its name
from a famous example a small-town
police officer has captured two
criminals and he wants to entice them to
confess so what he does is he creates a
structure of prison sentences where it's
advantageous for each of the prisoners
to confess regardless of what the other
one does we can illustrate a prisoner's
dilemma by thinking about the situation
of the United States and the Soviet
Union during the Cold War both sides
would have been happy to use the money
that they were building missiles with to
build school
and highways and hospitals but both
sides also realize that if they engaged
in unilateral disarmament they would be
at risk let's look at the structure that
governed the choice that those two
countries faced the United States
couldn't choose whether the Soviet Union
disarmed or not it could only choose
whether it disarmed the Soviet Union
couldn't choose whether the United
States disarmed or not it could only
choose whether it disarmed for both
countries their first choice was that
the other country disarmed while they
kept their weapons let's think it
through from the perspective of the
United States if the Soviet Union
disarmed and the United States kept its
arms the United States was better off it
was getting its first choice if the
Soviet Union didn't disarm and the
United States kept its arms it was
better off it was getting its third
choice which is certainly better than
its fourth choice of unilaterally
disarming so the rational thing for the
United States to do regardless of what
the Soviet Union did is to keep its arms
in so doing it guaranteed that it either
gets its first choice arming without the
other country doing so or its third
choice keeping its arms but at least not
giving up its arms when the other
country didn't and the situation was
exactly symmetric for the Soviet Union
and what that meant is that rather than
ending up in their second choice
situation the situation where I have
money to spend on my schools and
hospitals and Russia has money to spend
on its schools and hospitals both
countries in order to be rational needed
to spend resources on armament this
structure occurs over and over again in
human transactions
so unless there's some sort of
enforcement mechanism in place we will
end up like the US and the Soviet Union
during the arms race with our third
choice situation so the general problem
with which the prisoner's dilemma
confronts us is that if we behave in
rational ways we'll always end up not
cooperating it turns out that in lots of
small local interactions human beings do
manage to find a way out of this
scenario during the first world war the
Germans and the Americans develop a kind
of truce whereby soldiers from one side
could leave their trenches and get some
fresh air without getting shot and then
soldiers from the other side would leave
their trenches and get some fresh air
without getting shot the idea was that
as long as the other side was behaving
peacefully it was rational for you to
behave peacefully as well but if you
fail to cooperate or if it seems to me
that you have failed to cooperate I will
retaliate by not cooperating because of
the possibility that informal modes of
cooperation can break down Hobbes
insisted that in order to get out of the
state of nature we need my body that
regulates human interactions Hobbes
concludes that it's in our rational
self-interest to submit our will to a
sovereign whom he calls the Leviathan
and thereby to get ourselves out of the
state of nature
[Music]
let's fast-forward 300 years
Thomas Hobbes writes Leviathan a
half-century later philosopher John
Locke writes another book about social
contract theory and 50 or so years after
that the philosopher jean-jacques
Rousseau writes a similar work each of
them refining Hobbes notion of the
social contract together these three
pictures of what makes a state
legitimate allow the thinkers who lie at
the heart of the American and French
Revolutions to articulate a picture of
human rights that makes those
revolutions legitimate from the French
and American revolutions which give
voice to the citizens we move through
the 18th century to the emancipation of
the serfs in Russia and a general
democratization of society a recognition
that individuals votes should not be
dependent upon them being land holders
but should rather be open to people of
all social classes extending this idea
Karl Marx writes the Communist Manifesto
I mean the entire enormous nation Russia
in 1917 reshaped the fundamental
structure of its society in response to
a work of political philosophy at the
same time the tradition which gave rise
to the revolutions in the 18th century
one that says all human beings have the
right to have their voices heard gives
rise on the one hand to the women's
voting movement in England and America
and then to the civil rights movement on
United States soil expanding and
expanding out of Hobbes fundamental idea
that a government to be legitimate must
be in response to the needs of its
people we get during this 300 year
period an incredible opening
of political rights of a sort unknown in
the history of civilization political
philosopher John Rawls was born in the
early 20th century in the American South
he was of a generation where he and all
his friends went off to serve in the
Second World War and returned from that
war concerned with how it's possible to
create a stable and just society Rahl
spent most of his academic career
thinking about that question as a
professor of philosophy at Harvard
University and when he was in his early
50s in the middle of the 1960s and early
1970s as the Vietnam War was raging as
social protests were going on around him
as American Society was reshaping itself
in ways that voice was given to the
needs of the disenfranchised Rawls tried
to articulate in the great social
contract tradition a picture of what a
just society looks like and how a just
society should be structured it's in
this time that John Rawls sets out to
write his work the theory of justice
it's worth listening to the
extraordinary opening words of Rawls
book justice is the first virtue of
social institutions as truth is of
systems of thought a scientific theory
even if it's elegant is useless if it's
false a political structure even if it's
efficient is illegitimate if it's unjust
Rawls fundament
assumption in articulating what a just
society looks like is that each person
possesses a certain inviolability which
cannot be overridden even if doing so
would be of greater benefit to the
society as a whole in so doing he
challenges what had become a dominant
picture of what justice and morality
demand that picture can be traced to the
19th century works of the British
philosophers Jeremy Bentham and John
Stuart Mill and is known as
utilitarianism an act is morally right
if it produces the greatest good for the
greatest number of people if I face a
choice between saving one person and
saving five where I can save only one
group or the other utilitarianism gives
what many people find to be the
intuitive answer that I should save the
five thereby bringing about more
happiness rather than the one the
problem with utilitarianism that roles
is concerned with is that it seems that
in far-fetched and typical circumstances
utilitarianism could demand that we
violate the rights of the one to help
the many a famous counter example to
utilitarianism is that a healthy man
walks into a hospital where there are
five dying individuals one in need of a
heart one in need of a kidney one in
need of a liver two others each in need
of parts that he has the utilitarian
rubric would seem to suggest that if
those five can be saved by harming him
that that's what morality demands this
picture that each of us has inviolable
rights and that those rights can't be
overridden by the knee
of others is part of what's new and
exciting in Rawls discussion taking as
his premise the idea that justice is the
first virtue of social institutions that
is that no unjust society is a
legitimate one Rawls asks the following
question how should the benefits and
burdens of living together in a
community be distributed so as to best
realize what justice requires in
particular he asks what should the
fundamental institutional structures
look like to allow a society to be a
just society wall says a just society is
one that rational free and equal people
would choose to contract into but we
enter our interactions with one another
with all sorts of inequalities in place
some of us are wealthy some of us are
poor some of us are endowed with certain
kinds of intellectual or physical skills
that others lack if we try to build our
society taking into consideration those
facts about ourselves we aren't doing it
from a position of equality
Rawls insight is that sometimes the
fairest way to make a decision is to put
yourself in a position where you have
less information think about what the
fairest way to divide a cake is the
first way to divide a cake is to ask you
to divide it not knowing which piece
you're going to get if you divide the
cake unaware of which part will be yours
you will be inclined to divide it in a
fair way this is what
Rawls calls the veil of ignorance the
situation where you don't know who you
will be let's go behind the veil of
ignorance and ask a question that Rawls
asks namely which of the two principles
that he's derived ought to take priority
over the other do we care more about
fundamental rights or do we care about
the distribution of income so suppose
you're faced with a choice of three
societies in which you can live not
knowing what role you will play in the
society in society number one the
average income is $100,000 but only 85%
of the people have fundamental rights
only 85% of the people have the right to
vote liberty of conscience the right to
a fair trial in the second society the
average salary is $70,000 and only 85%
of people have fundamental rights in the
third society the average salary is
$70,000 but a hundred percent of people
have the right to vote freedom of
expression the right to a fair trial
which society would you choose to live
in when confronted with this choice set
anybody who's paying attention rejects
the second option it has all of the
disadvantages of the first and all of
the disadvantages of the third but it's
also true that when confronted with this
choice almost everybody rejects the
first option as well if you don't know
whether you're going to be one of the
ones with freedom then even though
you're guaranteed to have a higher
income in the first society than the
third more than 95% of people choose to
live in the third Society people want to
make sure that the bottom is safe
before they worry about what the top
looks like this idea that when you don't
know where you're going to end up you
have an inclination to be risk averse is
what lies behind Rawls conclusions about
what would be chosen from behind the
veil of ignorance so Rawls suggests that
to the extent there are inequalities in
a society they should satisfy two
conditions the first condition is that
the benefits of those inequalities be
accessible to all and the second and
perhaps most controversial part of Rawls
theory is that to the extent that there
are inequalities in a society they
should be distributed in such a way that
they are to the benefit of the least
well-off
so if it turns out that having a lower
tax rate in the highest bracket produces
wealth and income in a way that leads
those in the poorest quintile to benefit
Rawls says that's okay but if it turns
out that that's advantageous only to
those in the highest segment of society
that inequality says Rawls wouldn't be
countenanced from behind the veil of
ignorance it isn't a way that people
would choose for a society to be
structured if their fundamental concern
was with justice in 2005 two
psychologists inspired by the work of
John Rawls decided to survey several
thousand
randomly selected Americans about what
they thought the distribution of income
would look like in a society of which
they would want to be apart and they
presented those citizens with two
different pie graphs in one the vast
majority of wealth was held by the top
quintile of society and a small amount
by the second quintile with virtually
none held by the remainder of the
society in the other the distribution
was more equal roughly a third of the
wealth was held by the top quintile and
the remainder was distributed among the
remaining four given the choice between
those two social structures 92% of
Americans chose the bottom as a matter
of fact the top graph which only 8% of
subjects chose represents the actual
distribution of wealth in contemporary
America one might ask how does a society
come to have the wealth distribution
that our society does the answer of
course is that when we engage in day to
day interactions with one another we
don't do it from behind a veil of
ignorance we do it in a way that
reflects our self-interest and those of
us who have the resources that wealth
provides find themselves in a position
to gain more and more wealth those of us
who find ourselves in a position without
the resources that wealth provides often
find themselves unable to move in to
different ways of living does that mean
our society is fundamentally unjust John
Rawls would give the answer yes
by contrast Robert Nozick would give the
answer no
well John Rawls was writing theory of
justice as a distinguished philosopher
in his mid-50s having fought in the
Second World War and then taught
philosophy for many decades thereafter
down the hall from him was a precocious
young man in his late 20s who had
recently started teaching at Harvard
that young man whose name was Robert
Nozick took upon himself the task of
writing a rebuttal to Rawls theory of
justice three years after theory of
justice was published
Nozick published his retort Anarchy
state and utopia Nozik was concerned
that Rawls had placed the wrong
fundamental notion at the center of his
theory it's worth hearing the book's
opening sentences
Nozick writes individuals have rights
and there are things that no person or
group may do to them without violating
those rights the minimal state limited
to narrow functions of protection
against force theft and fraud
enforcement of contracts and so on is
the most extensive state that can be
justified like Rawls Nozick is
challenging the utilitarian picture like
Rawls
Nozick thinks the goods of one person
can't be traded off the goods of the
community but unlike Rawls Nosek places
at the center of his political
philosophy not the notion of equality or
justice but rather the notion of liberty
let's look
at what a society governed by Nozick's
principles might look like
Nosek famously articulates a view of the
conditions under which property is
legitimately held and his view is this
it's legitimate for you to own something
if you acquired it in a legitimate way
when it was unknown or if you acquired
it in a legitimate way from somebody
else who already owned it if I got the
property from you as the result of your
having given it to me then no one can
legitimately take that property away
from me this may sound relatively
uncontroversial but let's look and see
what it implies suppose each of us
starts out with the same amount of money
say each of us has $100 and there are
thousands and thousands of us all of
whom are fans of the great 1970s
basketball star Wilt Chamberlain so
suppose you give 25 cents of your money
to Wilt Chamberlain and I give 25 cents
of my money to Wilt Chamberlain and our
friend gives 25 cents of his money to
Wilt Chamberlain and so on thousands and
thousands of times until wolf
Chamberlain comes to have-nots $100 with
which each of us started out but
thousands and thousands and thousands of
dollars on notes expect any decision to
take away any of the money which Wilt
Chamberlain got through this voluntary
and legitimate transaction he's a
violation of rights then no distribution
of income including one in which 1% of
the people own 99 percent of the wealth
could ever be illegitimate because
what matters is how it actually came
into being if all that 99% of the wealth
came to those individuals as the result
of legal transactions then nothing can
be done without violating rights to
redistribute it there's no easy answer
to this question there's a strong
intuitive pole to the view that Nozick
advocates it is in some sense theft to
take from Wilt Chamberlain what each of
us has voluntarily given to him on the
other hand without such theft more
commonly known by the term taxation we
will find ourselves perhaps in the sort
of situation that neither walls nor
Nozick wants to be in instead of having
a society of which we're all equally
apart it may become the case that wilt
and his wealthy friends are able to buy
access to the media are able to buy
advertising time for candidates that
they support are able to send their
children to schools where they gain
power and advantage and access to
resources with the result that the
fundamental rights which knows it as
well as Rawls was concerned with
preserving become difficult for people
to exercise the Wilt Chamberlain example
illustrates a general phenomenon which
we face in a society individual
decisions that are acceptable may be
problematic if large numbers of people
make those decisions the problem that
this gives rise to is called the tragedy
of the Commons so suppose there's a
green area where I let my cow graze
you let your cow graze and our neighbor
lets his cow grace so far no problem for
each of our cows there's enough to eat
but suppose that each of us instead of
having one cow has 50 if you alone had
50 cows there would be no problem if I
alone had 50 cows there would be no
problem but if hundreds of us have 50
cows the entire green space will
disappear and all of our cows will die
this structure manifests itself in
situation after situation overfishing
results from each of us taking what
would be a fine amount of fish if we
were the only ones doing it but an
amount that becomes problematic if
others are doing likewise each of us
polluting a small amount causes no
problem all of us polluting together can
lead to drastic consequences
let's return to our for opening
questions and ask what Rawls and Nozick
would say about them with respect to the
question of whether society should
guarantee universal health care Rawls
would say yes and Nozick would say no on
Rawls picture health is a precondition
for participation in a civic society and
from behind a veil of ignorance clearly
everyone would choose a society in which
they had the guarantee of safety by
contrast on Nozick's
this provision would be possible only as
the result of illegitimate interference
in people's lives with respect to the
question of whether an inheritance tax
is legitimate Rawls would say yes
Nozick no Rawls says each of us has the
right to be born into a roughly equal
community and those who inherit large
amounts at the moment of birth are
advantaged in ways which presumably is
not to the benefit of the least well-off
Nozick by contrast wonders where Rawls
gets the idea that it's anybody's
business to tell me whether I can give
my money to my children with respect to
the third question should the army be
constituted by draft or by volunteers
Rawls would at least in conditions of
wartime advocate a draft army just as
the benefits and rights of a society
that our fundamental need to be
distributed equally across all so to
honor Rawls picture must the burdens the
only fair way to distribute those sorts
of responsibilities is as the result of
a random process Nozick by
contrast would be happy with a volunteer
army individuals have the right to
contract into risk and the fact that
most of the individuals who contract
into risky situations are those for whom
there are not so many options isn't
something that would bother Nozick
though of course under both
circumstances there are many who would
choose to serve their society simply out
of a desire to protect it finally with
respect to the question should it be
legitimate to sell your vote Rawls gives
the answer no that's a right that he
considers unalienable unalienable
because from behind a veil of ignorance
we saw that no one would choose to live
in a society where such rights weren't
distributed equally Nozick by contrast
thinks that this like everything else
should be something which is your
discretion to choose and if you decide
that one of the best ways for you to
finance something that you care about is
by selling your vote to another person
what business is it of anybody else to
tell you that you can't you I imagine
have your own answers to those four
questions perhaps they line up
completely with one or the other of the
authors that we've discussed but what
you now have in addition to your answers
to those questions are some tools for
thinking about why you give those
answers what political philosophy and
philosophy in general encourages you to
do is to step outside the specificity of
your own situation Hobbes and Rawls and
Nozick all recognize that each of us
wants more rather than less of a share
of the goods of our society but what
they ask you to do is to think about how
the fact that you want more rather than
less suggests that everyone else
probably does too
when I graduated from college I spent a
couple of years doing education policy
work and then decided to go back to
graduate school to study philosophy in
1990 I was lucky enough to enroll as a
graduate student at Harvard University
where two of my teachers were the
political philosopher John Rawls and a
man who ended up being my dissertation
director Robert Nozick it's from the two
of them that I learned what I know about
political philosophy philosophy has
always been connected to the works that
are going on in other fields at its time
in ancient Greece the philosopher
Aristotle was not only doing work in
metaphysics and epistemology he was
collecting constitutions from various
other Greek city-states to provide the
first catalogue of political systems he
was doing biological experiments and
thinking about the nature of physics
this has been true throughout
philosophies history that it's great
thinkers think not only about questions
central to the discipline but also about
how those questions relate to the fields
around them people who major in
philosophy in the 20th century have gone
on to do a huge range of things they go
to law school they go to business school
they go to medical school
some of them go on to be philosophers in
a professional sense but what
philosophers typically go on to do is to
be thoughtful reflective participants in
whatever they end up doing whether that
be working in real estate or working as
a nurse or being a full-time parent or
being mayor of their town the most
profound questions of the world are the
ones which philosophy gives you
permission to ask and to learn how to
answer and it's for that reason that the
study of philosophy can be an enormous
ly illuminating and valuable part of
anyone's life thank you
[Music]